ahora vamos a encontrar el valor de esta
masa misteriosa y lo vamos a hacer
utilizando matemáticas las matemáticas
son solo un lenguaje el uso de símbolos
para establecer relaciones entre las
cosas y te invito a construir una forma
matemática de expresar esto que estamos
viendo aquí lo que está pasando en esta
balanza y te voy a dar algunas
sugerencias por ejemplo podemos pensar
que las masas de los objetos que están
en los brazos de la balanza son iguales
veamos que es lo que tenemos en el lado
izquierdo el primero puede observar que
tenemos nuestra masa misteriosa que la
vamos a denotar con la interrogación
pero no es lo único que tenemos y
también tenemos tres kilogramos así que
voy a escribir la interrogación para
nuestra masa misteriosa que también está
en kilogramos
+ 3 kilogramos
y que tenemos del lado derecho tenemos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez diez kilogramos si lo
que tenemos son diez kilogramos y qué
más podemos saber pues bien podemos
saber que las masas de ambos lados son
iguales porque la balanza está en
equilibrio de la manera en la que fue
dibujada esa balanza está en equilibrio
entonces sabemos que estas dos cosas son
iguales y que es lo que hemos hecho pues
construimos una ecuación en la que
tenemos nuestra masa misteriosa con la
interrogación y que es nuestra incógnita
a la que si le sumamos tres es igual a
diez y teniendo esta ecuación podemos
resolver para la incógnita y podremos
saber esta incógnita qué valor tiene en
el vídeo anterior aprendimos que si yo
quiero saber el valor de esta masa
misteriosa tendría que remover estos
tres kilos que están del lado izquierdo
pero también aprendimos
hacer algo para que la balanza se
conserve en equilibrio eso fue lo que
vimos en el vídeo anterior entonces
tendremos que remover 3 kilogramos de
ambos lados quitar 3 de un lado y 3 del
otro para conservar el equilibrio y
matemáticamente sería equivalente a
restar 3 de ambos lados porque si yo
restará nada más de un lado ya no serían
iguales entonces tenemos que restar 3 de
ambos lados así que restar hemos 3 de
cada lado de manera que conservemos la
balanza en equilibrio del lado izquierdo
que tendremos pues se quedará solo el
símbolo de la interrogación
entonces del lado izquierdo se queda
solo la interrogación y del lado derecho
que tenemos 10 menos 3 que es 7 sí 10
menos 37 y lo mismo se observa nuestro
dibujo nuestra masa misteriosa es igual
a 7 kilogramos la interrogación es igual
a 7 kilogramos como aquí se puede
observar